[Music] [
Music
] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music
] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Laughs]
[Music]
technology well not
to drive  but will also
[Music]
it's
your Identity
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music]
[Music]
[Music
] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music
] [Music
] [
Music]
[Music]
[Clap  hands]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music
] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music
] [
Music]
[Music]
[Music
] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
I don't drink and it's normal
it's just me and God knows
it's just a lie because I was forced to
admit I was forced to admit
that I was a victim even though there wasn't
[Music] [
Music]
what they did was very
unethical yes I said evil evil because
I shared the photo on  in a group
they know that there Buy
porn videos covered with pornographic photos
[Music]
that then they also take
when they run out of material quotes
they also take from other groups
like Wawan also joins in
international groups when there are photos from
that group will  also put it on the Facebook group
[Music] the
photos they share
mostly take place in public places
children are walking on the beach
children are walking at the zoo
then the photos are shared directly to
the group and that is very dangerous
according to
I saw some of
the conversations, lots of tips, which later
became part of the group.
I got to know the internet when I was 8
years old. I did the internet or I didn't
learn it myself
[Music]
My small community is a quiet introvert.
I prefer to play with
my gadgets than other people
[  Music]
When I was little, I loved playing internet cafes. I was so
happy to go to the cafe. I
walked for 1 hour to the cafe
until there was activity. Finally, I have one
job, namely an internet cafe operator. So
yeah, where is my life
and he often spends his time at
the cafe, even our opponents say he is
Finally, he tried to enter the Deep web and
yes, that's the term Pedophile
[Music]
He was raised by his own lips,
raised as a program background, he
couldn't afford it, he didn't graduate
until he finished elementary school.
[Music]
Wawan comes from a
family on the edge
when they found a group  and
they feel Wow in this group I
am the leader I am the leader
like that I can control
many people
Wawan is proud proud of my friends
a lot of international
[Music]
he is Naive he can deny that he
has never had intercourse with
small children that  he is not a pedophile but one
he shares a photo and also knows
that there is a tendency that the
photos shared are photos of
small children and all kinds of child sex videos
and he closes his eyes and he
deliberately closes his eyes he enjoys
his pride as admin
[Music  ]
at first there was a lot of it about
Why did you continue it I didn't
continue it so I'll explain again
not continue or don't continue
I'm rarely active too I
comment just the usual comments after that first it
looks like he doesn't really or doesn't
feel guilty
then second
he felt he was a victim and the
third one he clarified that he
was not the culprit he was not this meant
not just to be a pedophile and
so on
[Music]
from March 20 2017 we did
cyber Patrol
cyber Patrol which then we found
that there was a Facebook group there
called  rally Candy which he then
contained, namely about monograph paint and
also a report from the public
regarding the case. Then
based on that report, we did not
proceed with the Undercover
project, this is one of the
biggest cases that we have managed to
uncover at this time
[Music]
1 apart from the perpetrator  is from Indonesia
himself he is also the administrator
or administrator of
other groups which are then affiliated with
international groups.
From the beginning we carried out the investigation,
we got around 6000 members
that we got on Facebook,
then because it only took about a
week to carry out the investigation,
we just  I was also shocked when
I found that these members had
added to 8,000 more
[Music], a
total of around 10,000 photos
and videos,
of course I was shocked at first
and horrified to see that Facebook, the
product Candy, turned out to be so
good at sharing data or
information or  photos and videos
related to young children
[Music]
of course We as parents
have children who have concerns
that Facebook is not only the
only means of communication between
them but they also create
other groups, namely the WhatsApp Group
and the telegram group  where from the
WhatsApp group itself We found
involvement or links with
other countries involving
more than 46 countries then containing around
11 groups and one group from Indonesia
with more than 8000 members
[Music]
because they know that  Facebook will
censor what
they upload and then band
their accounts when they
post things that are considered vulgar
by Facebook, so they switch to the
WhatsApp Group
compared to those on Facebook, the
WhatsApp Group is indeed more
vulgar. So they are bolder  speak up
they are braver to share
photos and videos Real
[Music]
s
the user this or
[Music]
device
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
meant group for anime we
discuss anime game spoilers and what is
anime online  What that means is what's
airing right now,
so it's not me making the original,
and after a few
months, the account disappeared,
so the old members I already
know asked me to make a new
tree, it's called the brain, he's the main admin,
then he's in charge of helping, then
sifting  my active
ideas and Deden are of course members and they are
also admins and the most routine
then upload videos and photos
[Music] I
think he's interested Wawan
and he just Oh I already have
this boyfriend I have to obey my boyfriend
like this like this maybe feel
this is wrong  but then my boyfriend is also
involved here like that this is
just for fun like that
your boyfriend is not a close friend
I know him on Facebook know know
know know Turns out we were talking about
anime and we connected so
I invited him to the group I probably  it's
better with him like that maybe
he can be more active in
engaging with the environment in my group.
make him the admin
[Music]
OK, maybe the one who is more active is the idea, right?
Because he's a person who's still at school,
so when he's finished school, he
still has a wide range of sound so he can still
use it to arrange
[Music]
Initially, I made Ilu,
Ilunayah, become admin  because he's
the closest to me. When we
first chatted, we met on the Indonesian website.
[Music]
Well, in my group, he is very interested
in anime as well as anime OSTs,
because there were many requests from members
to make the second one.
[Music]
official oil Candy acting
Plus, what does it mean, so that
only adults who join there
don't have ABG children who
post carelessly for that purpose,
so I want to discuss adult pornography too, the
people are already
adults
and we were there before, if I'm not mistaken, I made
one  rules for
posting pornography after
10pm until morning
[Music]
We've made the second group, the
first one we didn't do like that
because we're tired. It's better to take
care of people like that.
They just upload photos, maybe
I'm just a child naked, only
censored
porn videos,
child porn videos are also there
[Music]
but I'm broken, so I don't monitor
the group at all
and even in internet cafes I rarely open
Facebook because at that time I was  I
like to play games, so I don't
have time to open Facebook, I do
n't take care of it anymore,
because I'm tired of
typing people every day, so it interferes with
my activities,
I do it at night.
Wa Bang,
how come there are posts like this on Facebook,
Ouch, every day there are lots of people like
that, I'm tired, just leave it up,
it's up to you,
so you manage me while working
at an internet cafe,
make that group account. When I started
monitoring me, wow, this is not true
That's right Then I made one person
but that one person has many accounts,
has 5 clone accounts
like that So they post non-stop and
we're tired of typing every day
Why do you continue with the second one
because I usually Look for referrals there
[Music  ]
[Music]
So I'm in the game link section,
but I use Ads add fly
Advertising, usually I get Rupiah
from there.
Rp. 20,000 Yes, it's only enough
to buy a data package, he said,
another admin. Usually, they share
photos and videos in the hope of being rewarded with
pulses worth Rp. 25,000
or Rp. 50,000.
This is
the motive.
full so he is diligent in
sharing there is sexual satisfaction
but you end up feeling attracted
to children
not at all like before
Curious, curious, but
interested or
not, curious because in the video in the
video that I saw, this little boy
looks like  I've been taught that, how come you
're not afraid, it's okay, how come you can do
this, right? In general, it's innocent, if you ask strange people, they're definitely scared, and what I see is the opposite,
I read that six small children who were
victims of Wawan 3 have already admitted that  If
Wawan ever got close, OK, at that time,
at first, I was forced, so this is honest,
what I said was in my heart, I was forced
to admit, and it turned out that I asked for
evidence of a post-mortem examination, it was not even stated at the trial,
it was also not stated that I could check,
if you don't believe, there were no victims at the trial
because the post-mortem evidence  no
I want to ask, woi, here is
one of your posts.
[Music]
We can confirm that the evidence that we
got is of course the opposite
of what was obtained from the results
or what Wawan said, that is,
apart from distributing the photos and videos,
he is also the one who made the photos and videos
as well as  the direct perpetrators
of the children themselves
among the perpetrators who were among the
victims he was a neighbor
and his nephew he did that
by luring the child
to want to play with him
before finally
groping and also penetrating
tourist destinations in Indonesia  this is
often referred to as Suga Pedophile of
the world like that this is data from 2010 to
2015 based on UNICEF Indonesia so
this figure is very worrying
I don't know what makes
Indonesia sex education for children
is still a bit taboo in Indonesia to
explain that this is what is
called sex  even though it's just
being held by foreigners
from the government and there should be
intensive law enforcement too, yes,
for pedophiles, what's
lacking is the high level of
vigilance.  and people's awareness that they have the
courage to say no,
sometimes in the context of politeness.
It's not allowed to be so impolite with
these guests.
-children
one of them is when they finish
exercising at school with a
sweaty body they get satisfaction
by just smelling the child's own sweat.
they are their own nephews. In fact, they also
commit violence and then
video it and share it with themselves,
something we need to be aware of that
sometimes we think that pedophiles are
only men, when in fact women
can also be women, they can also
get satisfaction from having
sexual intercourse  with men who are
still classified as children so it means that
not only girls and
boys can also
admit that they are in the group but
he denied that he was actively sharing
photos of children and all kinds
[Music]
ready to say no  he is not interested
in young children because he is more
interested in Wawan,
in fact these videos
are really congenital factors, but
there are also environmental factors, so there is an innate factor in his
psycho-
sexual development, so he prefers
children  so that it will continue to
target children.  the
perpetrator the victim is forgotten
like a wound if it is not
treated immediately eventually it will also cause a
scar. This defect is also a defect in
this psychological aspect which then becomes
something very complex so that
he might become the perpetrators in the
following periods including the
initial B, including  also
said that too
[Music]
at that time when I was 7 years old I
had experienced sexual harassment My
neighbor was a distant neighbor so every time I went to
school he passed in front of his house he was
afraid
I didn't say anything Because in the past I was
threatened if I went through there it would be nothing
I won't survive like that So I'm afraid I shut my
mouth and I also talk to that person,
can't I confide in that person
?  it's actually a
new type of pornography that I never knew about
because it was the first time I knew about it.
When I found out it was a crime, I
wanted to leave the group,
but I didn't have time to stay.
my husband went to school and went to the
office
[Music]
someone shared keyword.com that
said there was a loliken group in
their name I shared it with my group
called fans delicious I told
them that for example there was a group
called Loli Candy that was targeting
children
the response from my friends at first didn't
believe them they thought I was too paranoid too
afraid of spreading hoaxes
[Music]
quite a lot in Indonesia
I measure from this yes The fact check team
can check 5 times a day whether
this news is true or not
like that
five times a day the news  hoax check
the original Try to imagine if in one
month there could be 150 million but it was
already very massive
[Music]
We had several people, 4 people
joined the group to group to group to
see if it was true or
not
[Music]
that  the first time I saw it when I
saw the group I was actually
surprised, because there were so many of
them, of the thousands of
photos, there were naked children,
photos of the average child that
they shared, even from a baby, sis,
9 months old.  I've been there until the age of
10,
which I'm surprised there are not only
children in their environment who
they
sexually abuse, but they also want to take
photos from people's social media accounts to
be commented on sexually.
The conversation I saw in that group was
one of them  is how to
prevent minors from
bleeding when molested.
What are the tips? How can
children also not complain to their
parents.
private all
In the end it's just me and
my husband's family in Pariper I'm
just
collecting screenshots like
collecting photos of the children of their victims
[Music]
We are relieved and thank the
police for taking the
complaints of mothers seriously
[Music]
there are also rules that are quite surprising
to us, one of which is that you
have to prove that the photos and videos
that are being shared are genuine,
this video is deliberately
proving that you can share the
original photos or videos to
get a response or get
satisfaction so that they are
well known  among the other members,
those who participate in this group
besides sharing, there are other interactions
that have to be bartered, there must be other communication that really shows they are active here,
and if they get any photos,
they have to write a caption,
where is the location from?  the origin is
to ensure that the photo really
exists. So that they don't
match what was said earlier,
if they also have one of the
rules or one of these members, they
have a habit of
proving that the video or photo
sent by them is genuine
by writing the day, date or
the name of the person to whom it is intended is sent
to prove that these photos and
videos are
real, not taken from other social media.
Facebook is stricter in terms of
filtering what is posted on
Facebook, so on Facebook they
try to use
certain codes, for example the word  -CP and
others said it was to hide that
they didn't hide it
vulgarly. There
was still sexual interaction in it.
It was forbidden by them because it
was automatically banned on Facebook.
Now, the other rules are if
you want to post something that is
too vulgar, it's better  censored,
for example,
what color did the censor use, what emoticon did the
genitals
use, what emoticon did you use, don't
give the blue one, I mean the blue link,
for example, if we post the link, it will
automatically turn blue and because
the link is active, they will give
directions if you want to post it  link in section
eg
linkmega.nz Mega dot space NZ Well it
won't turn blue
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
they store uncensored photos or videos
in a special site but
from there later when  the video has been
censored it's showing people who need the
full video will contact the admin Well
later the admin will give the site
that well this is what's interesting one
interesting element Why then there are
so many members in this group up to 7000
is because the site provided by
Wawan and other features for
storing  there are
very few uncensored videos so it's like we don't
have to click on the server and
many times.
us
so we also know that Wow,
then we can't stay long
because we can't share the
videos or photos that are requested to
prove the activity of the members. As soon as
these 4 members accept or these 4 mm1
accept us as members, we
have also prepared various reasons to
wasting time while looking for data on the
perpetrators who were there
[Music]
we asked for help from Facebook to
track down or get information on
other perpetrators
if indeed we did a
check first to
make sure that this was Real or
Anonymous in language  the cyber,
but we also got there at
that time there was a contact person who
happened to be from their phone number
[Music]
Wawan He once took an
open photo of his own neighbor,
a demo photo of a small child was shared with
the group
and it turned out that there was a license plate so
the police could  track it down
[Music]
we decided at that time we had a meeting
to form a team divided into 44 to
make the arrest
together it was quite
challenging for us
according to our discussion yesterday your case
Candy was successful according to the analysis
we found that there are four subjects
that we will do  equipment
coincidentally the places are in
different places. So,
friends' analysis, we found that we
have to make arrests
simultaneously. You can't make
arrests on different days or
separately. Why, because according to the
preliminary analysis, they already have a
code.
something they will shade everything
and we will lose the data
we need
when a neighbor recognizes
that it is possible that the opposing subject is in
the house then we check again
from the photo on Facebook that there is
one corner of the building that was photographed
with him now  it turns out that the building is what
makes us sure that the
photo is a photo of part of
Wawan's house. In fact, it
turns out that he has quite a network,
maybe yes, in a pretty
good network in his area. He got
information that someone was looking for him. He
was able to update his status.
he said that if it was a
friend, I should just get straight to it,
don't ask questions. Now, with the
status update, we are even more convinced
that the house is indeed the house
that Wawan lives in.
distributing
pornographic content the police arrested two
doophilia perpetrators and two perpetrators who
were in charge of spreading the video, one
of them was a 16-year-old young girl. It was
formed in September 2016
with
7479 members, 8 new victims, yes.
other groups, both on
Facebook and on WhatsApp, where there is a
photo in the
picture on the cellphone in
question,
for those international or outside
Indonesia, we tried to contact
other law enforcement officers via
sunset, namely
[Music],
we managed to secure Wawan,
namely 3 cellphones. Then several
usb flash drives from the 3 cellphones
and from these flash drives we can
get
around 2000 files containing photos
and videos about pornographic chats
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]